we can now talk to the liberal democrat
leader
ed davey who is of course campaigning
ahead of those local uh elections uh
good to uh see now mr davey so what does
a good set of election results look like
for the local uh for the lib dems next
week well i've been going up and down
the country talking to people um and
there's no doubt that they are extremely
cross and disappointed with the
conservatives lifelong conservative
voters feel they're being taken for
granted they're really worried about the
cost of living crisis uh alarm that the
conservatives response is to
increase taxes uh on them and it looks
like boris johnson doesn't care and
doesn't have a plan and liberal
democrats are saying there should be a
big tax cut for people and that is going
down well so how that works out i'm not
sure but i do think we'll make progress
uh and i do think people are switching
to the liberal democrats
um so you think you make progress you
think people are switching to the lib
dems um we were talking to the labour
leader
there he denied any kind of electoral
pact going on with the liberal democrats
but if you look at the numbers i guess
people will wonder if there is some kind
of quiet alliance going on in the
northeast for example you're standing in
56 percent of seeds compared to 78 four
years ago that's an area where labour's
standing in 99 of seeds
is there some kind of pack going on and
to be frank you know some on the left
might think that's a very good idea
there's no pack now there's not going to
be a pact in the future uh liberal
democrats are actually fighting labourer
in many areas in hull in sunderland in
sheffield in haringey in southwark and
i can take you to many other places
where there's a a real fight and you
know these uh council numbers i think
are a bit of a distraction pretty
desperate from the conservatives let's
remember they always fluctuate from
election to election and actually
conservatives are uh fielding uh over a
hundred fewer candidates this time
okay uh thank you and now i'm interested
to know about a by-election uh coming up
as well one that you might be
eyeing up slightly neil parish of course
we'd talk about him this morning the mp
who's resigned
over the allegations or actually i
shouldn't even say allegations anymore
because he's admitted it to watching
pornography in the house of commons
he of course is the mp for tiverton and
homerton
is that a by-election you think you
could win
first of all i'm really uh pleased that
he's resigned it was uh utterly
unacceptable it's right that he he went
it took a little bit longer than i'd
like but it's right he's gone so there
will be a by-election in tibetan and
hunterton and uh i believe the liberal
democrats can be the real challenges in
that we have a real legacy of success
across the south west we've shown in the
north shropshire by-election where we
were third at the previous general
election but we
beat the conservatives no one gave us a
chance but in those rural communities
across north shropshire we found
lifelong conservatives feel that they've
been taken for granted that things like
this health service they they felt the
conservatives were betraying and so in
those rural communities i think liberal
democrats can make real real uh inroads
and stride so uh i'm looking forward to
that by election and i think we will be
challenging the conservatives hard
it's interesting isn't it because it
does feel like you are really trying to
target some of those true blue shires
you and i will remember the absolute
drubbing
that the liberal democrats uh got at the
hands of the conservatives after of
course going into that coalition
is this the first signs that things are
rebuilding or could this be yet another
false dawn because let's be frank we
we've had all these optimistic chats
before i've interviewed lots of lib dem
leaders with smiles on their faces
before and then it all comes crumbling
to nothing at the ballot box
well to be fair sophie we've been
building steadily over the last two
years if you look at our local election
results i was proud of what we achieved
in may last year and then of course we
had those two historic by-election
victories in true blue buckinghamshire
uh in cheshire and amisham where no one
expected the liberal democrats to beat
the conservatives but we did and i
talked about the blue wall across the
south east where we're now challenging
lots of conservative mps and then the
north shropshire by-election a seat that
concerted held for 200 years and then if
you look at council by-elections this
year across the whole of the country uh
which party has been winning the most
it's been the liberal democrats so there
is steady success and i hope next
thursday we can build that and make make
more progress
and go taking that into the general
election now if we want to get boris
johnson out of downing street which
double democrats really want to do
only the little democrats can beat the
conservatives in many many seats
and we we have to be part of that uh
ejection of the conservatives and given
their failing to help millions of
pensioners and families with a
cost-living crisis they don't seem to
have any plan at all they don't seem to
care liberal democrats have a real plan
with this
bold tax cut that's v80 tax cut worth
600 pounds on average to to families
across the country
i think people are looking to us now as
an opposition to the tourists in many of
their heartland seats
okay and i want to talk to you a little
bit about the misogyny stories we've
seen in westminster we've been talking
about a lot on the show today
and it's everything from inappropriate
behavior in house of commons bars
to junior members of staff being badly
treated to of course the infamous
example of an mp watching pornography in
the house of commons
i'll be i'll level with you i've been
slightly frustrated by the lack of
concrete suggestions put forward by
guests so far this morning lots of big
words but perhaps not in the way of
actual concrete changes
that can be made what do you think needs
to happen specifically
to stop us having to have the same
conversation about misogyny in the
commons every couple of years
well sophie you're absolutely right this
has been going on far too long and
this appalling behaviour that we're
seeing is unacceptable misogyny the
sexism the treatment for example angela
rainer this is going to put women and
girls off from coming to our politics
that's damaging to our country so we've
got to act let me give you one or two
concrete examples we should be looking
at how mps employ their staff
some people have been putting that
forward let's look at that properly
that's a concrete example look at the
independent complaint system although
it's relatively new and i strongly
support it
there are concerns that it's too slow
let's speed that up and give staff and
other mps confidence that action will be
taken quickly and not and things not
just kicked into the long grass we have
to restore confidence we have to
get rid of this appalling misogyny and
sexism in our politics and frankly in
our wider society
we've got to respect women and girls far
more we've got to show them with
concrete actions that's what we are
going to do
talking concrete actions would you be in
favor of quotas for female mps or
perhaps shutting bars in the house of
commons
well um
i'm happy to look at everything i i'm
very proud that i lead a liberal
democrat party party which has majority
women
over two-thirds of our mps in parliament
for the liberal democrats are women and
we've managed to do that without quotas
and i'm determined to make sure that we
are as diverse as possible as a party
party
and you know we need to make progress um
i'm happy to look at any measures and
have that discussion
but i'm pleased the liberal democrats
have already made made real progress
okay uh thank you very much ed davey
they're the leader of the liberal
democrats